ooh ooh ooh i'm getting a little hit of
spice there
[Music]
hey i'm sarah beth and i'm a former
chick-fil-a employee
i'm brian and i used to work at
mcdonald's hi my name is diana flores
and i'm a former worker for wendy's
my name is crystal and i am a former
burning king employee
i'm marissa and i'm a former employee of
kfc hi my name is josh
and i used to work at popeyes so the
perfect chicken nugget to me
it's gotta have like that crunchiness to
it a little bit greasy
i want to know that it's not like super
healthy i want to be able to see it kind
of glisten in the light a little bit
i don't really like spice to my chicken
but
definitely not too salty
the reason why i love chick-fil-a's
chicken nuggets it's real chicken
that they cook right then for you and i
think that's what makes it
so good right off the bat i can smell
the flavors
zooming through my nasal cavity a little
on the smaller side but i mean that's
you know not the size of the boat the
motion of the ocean so that's okay
it tastes like it's fresh like if the
chicken was just like brought to the
restaurant today
my favorite thing about chick-fil-a
nugget is the breading to chicken ratio
is so perfect there's those little
crunchy bits in there which are like the
best
oh bomb so much flavor
right off the bat the breading is
amazing i think the seasoning is
definitely in the breading and they
didn't like sprinkle nothing on it
that's how you know
and i could probably eat about like at
least 36 more of these
this just feels like an actual like a
natural chicken nugget
look how much chicken is in this nugget
i had to rank that on a scale of one to
ten
i'd give it a 10. because i've never had
a chicken i feel like probably get
around
like an eight i want to say an eight i
give it like a seven
solid but you know if there's another
place next door i'll probably go there
instead
[Music]
i grew up with mcdonald's chicken
nuggets i have a personal
connection with them i like that they're
shaped like like a weird state
what's this doesn't look
very fun to me it's kind of big but it
looks stale just by looking at it
it looks a little bit dry to me it could
be crispy so maybe it'll be a positive
thing but
i'm a little skeptical i already know
what this is
and i already know they're going to be
good just because these are bombs so i'm
just going to bite it
my childhood one thing this has going
for it is the nostalgic factor for sure
i don't like this chicken tastes like
fake chicken i would say
that burger king nuggets look kind of
the same but the taste is definitely
better because these
are not that good yeah i don't like
these
like frozen's tail almost like you could
taste it
it was like in cardboard or something or
store it's like dr like
bendy i guess without breaking this is
my go-to
when it's late this is my go-to when i'm
driving this is my go-to when i'm in
another country and it's 3am and i can't
sleep
they're always there for me i rank this
a five
i'll give it a seven and a half not the
best but i don't hate it either it's
gonna be a little low
probably like a four seven i would
definitely keep eating those
i really don't want to do them dirty but
like maybe a six
they're better with sauce just saying
[Music]
kfc is the best because it's not just a
regular chicken nugget
it's got that popcorn chicken nugget
element to it so it's like
a little bit more unique it's what sets
kfc apart
and it's just the superior piece of
chicken all right that looks like a
popcorn to me
that is the chicken of the popcorn
variety the smell is not
exuding from them like the way the first
round of chicken nuggets was
oh that tastes good this is more crunchy
these chicken nuggets are really small
um it doesn't even look there's
chicken in here and they have like a
nice breading around it there's like a
like an aftertaste probably some sort of
weird chemical it has a
definitely like a unique spice that kind
of hits you right at the end it's a
little salty
and i don't really taste any chicken it
just tastes like breading some of them
have more like a breading forward taste
and this is definitely more like based
around the chicken i mean it's good if
this is what you go for but i don't
really like it i think for me
it's really the crunchiness because i
love
like crunchiness on fried chicken i
don't know if i consider this chicken
nugget but
i do enjoy it and if i had to rank them
on a scale
these would probably get like a four a
seven i would rank this
a four i feel like this is something you
would buy frozen
and then you would just cook it at home
i'll give this one like a seven
because it's still delicious who are we
kidding if i were to rank this as a
chicken
item i'd give it like an eight but if
i'm ranking it as a chicken nugget
i don't know if i can because i don't
consider this a chicken nugget so i'll
give these a four
i think popeyes has the best chicken
nuggets or chicken strips
just because they have the most flavor
and the most crunch
and you ever been to a pot pie they're
always hot and always fresh
oh whoa this looks like shrimp
is this shrimp am i uncultured i don't
know what this
is i love this place i like the texture
how it looks like it looks good the size
of it
is kind of not appealing it's scary
looking it looks like a like a finger
right off the bat it doesn't look
specifically appetizing
so the good news is it is chicken it's
not shrimp i can confirm
does chicken taste good home cooked soul
food like
i like it i like the seasonings man
these restaurants are slaying the spices
definitely more of like a southern fried
chicken kind of taste
something that you might have with like
a biscuit maybe
this is good this could be a whole meal
not too spicy not too bland it's kind of
like just
right it's got a lot of like moisture
it's kind of like greasy but in a really
good way
and the flavoring i think is what's
really selling me it like really pops
like immediately when it hits your mouth
there is
an upsetting lack of
spice on this there's no salt
no pepper like nothing like this could
use like a hit of cayenne
i'm not even sure what all is in that
but it's like it tastes like more than
just like bread and chicken
like this one definitely gets another
bite if i have to rank this one
i would probably give it um a seven
i'm gonna give it a good ten ten out of
ten
dude i might give this one a nine and a
half that's really good
i'd give it like like a six i would rank
it
in eight and i say eight because the
size is too big for me
like i don't know what's in there
[Music]
wendy's has the best chicken nuggets
because every time i bite into one
they're really juicy and they don't
taste like old or dry
where are these i don't know what these
are from a lot of tiny ones and i am
seeing a little bit of black pepper on
the
outside so that's good it looks like
this is about to be a little spicy here
i think i know where these are from
not really too much of the smell to it
so let's just go for it
no this is good it has a lot of moisture
in it it's like not dry whatsoever
the chicken looks weird i don't know how
i feel about these and i
am kind of sad about it so these are
like the kind that are like a little bit
more
soft like maybe ones that you would put
in your own oven at home and make
i'm into that that like dino chicken
nuggets you know flavor-wise it's pretty
good texture-wise it's good
ooh ooh i'm getting a little hit of
spice there
these are actually really good i'm not
sure where these are from but it's
crunchy and it looks really nice it has
like that golden
you know crust to it it makes you just
want to take a bite of it this is like
what you would
see on google when you've googled
chicken nuggets i'm definitely gonna
give this one an eight i really have no
idea where these are from
but i'm gonna give them another nine and
a half i give them like an eight
that was very good scale of one to ten i
would probably give these
a seven probably like a four as well it
doesn't taste
like edible if that makes sense burger
king we definitely had our
chicken nuggets well done that's for
sure
on my breaks i would always get chicken
nuggets with my crispy
chicken sandwich and some barbecue sauce
so i would definitely say
that burger king chicken nuggets are
pretty pretty
looks like it has pepper it's not spicy
is it is it spicy
it's a good shape it definitely looks
like it could be like a really obscure
u.s state i don't know what delaware is
shaped like but it could be that
these are warm too these these are all
warm chicken nuggets that's
this is what i like this is the kind of
chicken nugget i like the breading right
off the bat is like crispy you can feel
it let's try it
those are really salty it's that white
meat that's kind of like you know
probably put in a food processor all
smushed together and then smushed into
the shape of a chicken nugget
which i guess is what most chicken
nuggets are they're right they don't
really taste like chicken nuggets i
taste chicken
but it's weird it's like fake like vegan
like
stuff like soy stuff pretty crispy i'm
down for that
the breading like feels crispy but it's
actually not that crispy
it's a little bland i feel like if they
just gave us a little more salt
it doesn't really have too much flavor
to me let me down this was like a lie
from the beginning i thought it was
going to be really nice i don't hate it
it's nothing to write home about
it tastes a little bit peppery which i
guess is the only like good thing about
it
mmm the breading is so good i would get
a 12 pack of these on a scale of one to
ten i would probably rank it like
a three not that good i would rank this
chicken in eight
cause it tastes good to me it looks like
a chicken nugget
i think i would give them like a 9.5
because there's always room to improve
but these are pretty
bomb i think if i'm gonna rank this i'm
gonna give it like a four i'm gonna say
a six
so what i tell ya come on we all knew
what's gonna happen
chick-fil-a does have the best chicken
[Music]
nuggets
[Music]
you